20 years later the matrix is once again
asking us to make an ultimate choice
would you rather live comfortably in the
matrix
or wake up in a new terrifying reality
well brace yourself this computer now
controls your life down to the last
detail
what if your world was a simulation
how do we know what is real
could you ever trust your senses
would you find glitches in the code
and if this is a simulation who's
running the program
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you lived in the matrix
in this world neo isn't here to save you
and no one's offering you a pill to wake
up but
the architects who built this world
might have left some clues to help you
solve this mystery
you may not be the chosen one but
if you rely on your wits and your
instinct
you might outsmart this all-knowing
super computer
but if everyone you know is made of
pixels
does that mean
you might be a character in someone
else's simulation
in this classic film series the machines
control every aspect of human lives in
the digital world where they're trapped
imagine being stuck in a video game and
you're not even a player
that my friends is simulation theory
simulation theory states that all we
ever have
and will ever experience
are the results of a highly advanced
computer program
and all your senses and perceptions are
nothing more than digital experiences
made to simulate real life
it's even more terrifying that some
scientists have suggested there's a 50
percent chance we're living in a
simulation right now
but how big a supercomputer would it
take to run this artificial universe
well we'll come back to that
right now you need to find out if this
world is real or not
okay this digital world wouldn't be
perfect it would require updates from
time to time
during those moments you might be able
to see changes in the natural world that
wouldn't make sense
maybe you could test the speed of light
how would you do that
well you would need to create another
simulation within this one
jeez
how many layers does this world have
if you observed how light particles move
through your computerized world you
could compare those speeds to real life
well the real life you know
that may sound extreme but this
information could reveal a frightening
truth
and if this world might be fake
what about the people around you
in the original matrix trilogy a small
band of humans left the simulation and
led a rebellion against their robotic
masters
but the humans inside your simulation
may not be real at all so if you want to
get out of this place you'll need to
become friends with the ai that lives
here
starting deep conversations about the
nature of reality with these simulated
beings
might get them to consider their own
consciousness and what it means to be
real
yeah making a virtual friend could be
your best shot at escaping
in this franchise human bodies are kept
alive in goo filled vats with tubes
running down their throats all to power
the matrix
if you were in a simulation your body in
the real world could be locked up as
well but if your new ai friends find a
way to transfer your consciousness into
a machine
you could start a new life as a robot
and now
maybe you could see who's behind the
curtain
some theories suggest that the
simulations creators punish those
trapped within
making criminals live their virtual
lives in fear and pain
other theorists wonder if the simulation
is a game for a teenage alien who's just
killing time playing the program that
runs our lives
if that turns out to be true
it could mean
you're not even a real person
just a figment of someone else's
imagination
i think it's going really well try
playing the sims again now
but how could any of this be possible
an oxford philosopher suggested that to
run a massive simulated universe you
would need a supercomputer the size of a
planet
every emotion memory and landscape would
just be another piece of data
running inside this world within a world
and while neo and his friends made it
out of that simulation there's always a
chance you could wake up inside another
simulation that's within this one and go
further down the rabbit hole
but
what if
instead of this fake world
we made an artificial being beyond our
control
yeah what if we created a super
intelligence
we didn't learn anything did we
well i guess that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]